last question today David can you give
us an update of what's happening with
the Candace Owens debate that you said
you would be doing yeah so I'm gonna
tell you as much as I can tell you
because there are parties involved that
maybe it's not publicly known that
they're involved and I don't want to
it's not my place to name names so to
speak but there is a an organization
that came to me a few months ago and
said David we're in touch with Candace
Owens she has agreed to debate you and
we want to set it up and from the
beginning this was surprising to me only
because my understanding was that in
política back at politican in October in
Los Angeles I had been told that
politican approached Charley Kirk and
Candace Owens about doing a two versus
two debate with Kyle kolinsky and with
me and we were told they're not doing it
and there were different stories as to
whether they are were refusing because
they weren't being offered enough money
that's a pot I mean hey peek behind the
curtain politican pays people who go
okay and different people get paid
different amounts maybe it was a money
thing
maybe Candace and or Carly Kirk for
whatever reason decided they didn't want
to do the debate with me and with Kyle
we I don't know we were told she's not
doing it fine a month or two ago someone
on Twitter sentiment has tweeted to
Candace Owens and said hey why did you
back out of the debate with David Pakman
and she responded I don't know who David
Parkman is I just don't know what you're
talking about
so that may have been her playing coy it
may have actually been genuine and she
didn't know who I was at the time she
since blocked me on Twitter so the idea
that she has no clue who I am
increasingly sort of in question but
this is why when this organization came
to me and said Candace's people or
Candace have already said yes I said I'm
up for it but I have you know given the
backstory I have a hard time believing
it's just a straight up yes I send a
list of topics that I would want to do
the organization negotiating the the
debate said Candace's people have said
it's a go and some tentative dates were
even proposed all of those dates have
come and gone by at least
if not two or three weeks at this point
and the latest I've been told is that it
has gotten a little complicated I
genuinely don't know what the holdup is
is the holdup that Candice was
implicated in the manifesto of the New
Zealand terrorists and now they are
being extra protective of Candice is it
that again she's not getting enough
money to participate in this is it that
she doesn't want to appear somewhere
with me I genuinely have no idea I you
know my our my side my representation
has maintained we're just waiting for a
date and a confirmation of the topics
the one thing that did shift before
things slowed down was it reportedly
went from being a 1vs1 thing with a
moderator to being a sort of four-way
debate but not two versus two it was
going to be four people with different
political views I'm not gonna say who
the other people are because maybe it's
not even true that that they were
actually involved so it's gotten very
very messy I don't know the full scope
of what's going on we're checking in
about it every once in a while with
everybody who's involved I hope that it
happens I'm ready and I will give you
more information as soon as I have it on
today's bonus show I am going to give
you an update on what's going on with
YouTube D monetization and how it's
continuing and it's actually expanding
beyond news in politics so we'll talk
about that on the bonus show I also want
to talk about a study that is about the
impact of right-wing nationalism that
has been rising lately on the sort of
health of the world world health issues
that are related to rising right wing
nationalism which I think you will find
interesting and I will also tell you
about a sort of weird thing going on
with some people I'm friends with on
Facebook that's just a weird thing and
I'm not not super sure how to handle it
all of that and more on the bonus show
get access by being a member at david
pakman.com slash membership or by making
a patreon pledge of at least five bucks
a month at patreon.com slash david
pakman show that is everything I have
for you today
other than the bonus show if you love
learning new things you probably want to
check this out the david
when show today's sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to skill
share when you click the link underneath
this video skill share is a vibrant
online learning community offering more
than 25,000 video classes on just about
anything you can think of get better at
playing an instrument learn to use
Photoshop how to edit videos they have
classes on drawing painting business
cooking nutrition personal productivity
and I'm not even really scratching the
surface I recently took a great class on
introductory watercolour painting I'm
still not good but I am learning and you
can access the entire library of fun
easy-to-use online courses for free for
two months by using the link underneath
this video two months of learning
something that's totally new to you
something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it Pat has
taken some courses that he's found
really valuable and I think you'll love
it to get started for free by clicking
the link under this video